[Music]
hi everyone welcome to the ted interview
i'm stephen johnson
if you look back over the past few
centuries it's clear we've solved many
of the major mysteries in science i mean
we've sequenced the human genome and
split the atom we can detect radiation
that dates back to the big bang
but every now and then we get reminded
that there are still some big questions
out there that remain unanswered
take for instance the discovery just a
few decades old that the overwhelming
majority of the universe is made up of
some
mysterious substance
a substance we can't perceive directly
using any of our existing tools and
which doesn't seem to belong to any of
our known categories
a substance physicists now call somewhat
misleadingly dark matter
it's a profoundly humbling idea we know
so much about our universe and yet still
have so much more to discover
or as today's guest described it on the
ted stage in vancouver earlier this year
so we now know that the universe is more
queer and fantastical than it looks to
the naked eye
[Music]
that's right
that's theoretical physicist and author
dr chanda prescott weinstein who teaches
at the university of new hampshire
as you'll hear on this episode dr
prescott weinstein has a great gift for
explaining concepts from astrophysics
that can sometimes challenge our
earthbound hominid brains or at least my
brain
but she has another gift too a rare
ability to connect these vast ideas
about what's going on in remote corners
of the universe to human scale
experiences back here on our home planet
i think that's one of the reasons why
her first book the disordered cosmos has
received such rave reviews and been
dominated for so many awards because
it's a book about her pursuit of a
genuine scientific mystery that is also
grounded in her own life
story this is a conversation about the
nature of the universe
but it's also a conversation about how
great mentors can change your life and
how we can expose a wider and more
inclusive new generation of
investigators to the magic of science
[Music]
dr tronda prescott weinstein thank you
so much for joining us on the ted
interview we're really delighted to have
you here
thanks for having me
we have a lot to discuss
we have the nature of the universe
um political struggles your own
fascinating history um but in many ways
it's sparked by an extraordinary book
that you've written called the
disordered cosmos and i
i think one of the reasons why
this book has been so well received um
is it
it's really doing something that i i
can't think of a lot of precedent for
which is that it's weaving together
you know profound explanations and i
think really intelligible explanations
about the nature of the universe and
space-time and dark matter which we're
going to get into
with
your own you know personal and
intellectual journey
but also urgent discussions about you
know the lived reality today of systemic
racism and the history of colonialism
and oppression and sexual violence
but i did want to talk a little bit
about um
those early days and and how you got
pulled into this can you tell us
you know recreate some of that early
magic in your life and where it came
from
yeah so if you had asked me this
question before the tide conference i
would have given you a different answer
actually
and the thing that changed is actually
traveling to ted
i'm traveling to vancouver was my first
time getting on a plane since the
pandemic started
so you know a little over two years is
the longest i've ever gone in my life of
not being on a plane my first plane trip
was when i was two months old right so i
spent my life like flying back and forth
because my parents were divorced and i
was getting shipped away to family as a
kid to england i'm over the summers
so i thought i was gonna be totally
miserable getting on a plane again
particularly like wearing a mask and all
of that and then i was just so excited
to be in the sky
so what does this have to do with me as
a kid
my very first exposure to anything that
we might call physics was learning about
pressure above and below the wing of the
plane and why the plane stays aloft
that was my first exposure when i was 10
years old and i got like really obsessed
with it and i was just like constantly
like talking about all the physics-y
things that we were doing in class of
course i didn't know the word physics at
that point like i didn't or at least i
associated that with einstein but i had
no concept of
anything einstein did being related to
that
and i think because of that my
teacher told my mom that i needed more
science enrichment
wow and
so my mom took me to see errol morris's
a brief history of time the documentary
about stephen hawking
and halfway through the documentary
which i had like i had to miss x-men
cartoons that morning so i was like
really mad we were at a matinee
and halfway through the documentary
stephen hawking was talking about
solving
questions that einstein hadn't solved in
relation to black holes and i was like
wait that's a job
and that was like i was sold that was it
i was just like i can spend the rest of
my life doing math and get paid for that
and as a working-class kid i knew i
needed a job
so you're talking about the
amazement at
exploring black holes being a job you
could get paid for
tell us a little bit about your
upbringing like where were you raised um
and the context of that because that's
something that's woven through the book
for sure
yeah i mean i should say for context
that the reason that we were at a
matinee was because like that was all my
mom could afford right so i was i'm i
grew up in east los angeles
and
i'm we actually had to drive all the way
to the west side
and you know in hindsight thinking about
like the gas money for that like would
have been a real factor for my mom
but i think the other thing that
happened in that moment
was as a black kid from east l.a from
which is prime which is almost
exclusively at that point in time a
central american mexican-american and
immigrant community
we didn't see people like us doing
science and so it was definitely not
through the lens of
oh i see someone who seems like me doing
a thing and me realizing like oh people
like me can do that i didn't have that
experience with it
i do actually think it's meaningful
though that the science teacher that i
had at that moment mr wilson frank
wilson
um he still teaches at the los angeles
center for enriched studies which is
where i went on to go to high school
hopefully he's listening
yeah i hope he is um
it was meaningful to me that he was
black i think that that was he was my my
first science teacher my first math
teacher i did pre-algebra algebra and
physical science with him over the next
few years
but
you know my context was really like i
had to be able to connect with the ideas
and
you know i got lucky that i had that
kind of support where people were saying
yes you can do this and um
i think if i hadn't had that strong
connection with math and that strong
self-identification thanks to people
around me supporting me as like this is
a kid who's good at math
i might not have had that moment of
connection or i might have been like
that's a cool job for a white guy to
have
it's so important
those early
early teachers
who see something in you you know in
interviewing people over the years i can
think of it in my own experience as well
that
that sense of there's a grown-up in the
world who's seems to know a lot that you
don't yet know who detects something in
you and says hey we need to double down
on this there's something promising
there and then to add to that
as you say
having that person be a black man in a
world where
you're not associated with
traditionally black men with science um
that's just doubling empowering and and
i think that's something we we all
should think about a little bit more
when we're we're dealing with people
kind of early stages of their careers or
younger people it's like explaining that
those openings are there for people i
think is is a really important value to
walk around in the world with yeah i
i guess maybe it's worth sharing like
what happened on the back end of that
which is that like i had gone into the
movie theater like literally complaining
i have like very visceral memories of
like
documentaries are stupid like why are
you making me go to see this and then of
course like i have this moment like
somewhere in the middle where i'm like
wait this is what i want to do
i just want to pause just for one second
in case listeners have not seen that
errol morris movie i mean shout out to
morris can you imagine pitching that as
an idea so i want to make a movie
about astrophysics
and the star of it is someone who is
completely immobilized and can only
speak through a robotic voice um you
know that was not it was not clear that
that was going to be you know cinematic
gold but it's a brilliant movie and and
i think inspiring today even many years
later
yeah i mean i definitely think you know
i have
often wondered if part of why
i was able to draw that connection was
because stephen hawking didn't seem like
the stereotype of like an able-bodied
pets this white guy
um but he was he was different in his
own way
and so
there weren't all of kind of the
cultural affect necessarily that we
associate with someone
who might otherwise be embodied like him
and i think that that
may have made it easier for me to make
that connection and to see myself
and so then i'm coming out of the
theater and i'm like when can i have the
book are you buying me the book
and my mom is not saying to me like oh
we can't afford that she's saying to me
okay that's great that you're
enthusiastic and and genuinely like she
meant it but also that's a book for
adults and i'm afraid that you won't
enjoy it and so that was that was like
the way that she handled like
and in hindsight i should ask her about
this but in hindsight maybe that was her
way of being like i can't afford that
right now but i'm not i don't want to
say that um
my uncle her older brother my uncle
peter bought it for me for my 11th
birthday a few months later
which obviously like my mom had told him
to get it for me
and and then of course like it was a
book for adults and i was like an 11
year old with like trying to like read
about quirks and the standard model um
but there was this element that it was
like a community effort of you know mr
wilson having those conversations with
my mom about like what enrichment i
needed
i am you know my uncle chipping in
um you know part of what i point to in
the book is
i you know we can't rely on sometimes
researchers call this happenstance that
we can't really rely on happenstance
like that's not a fair system right
and so that's part of where my story
comes in is is picking out like the
pieces of saying
um you know
these were barriers to someone like me
and the fact that i got around them or
over them
doesn't mean that those barriers don't
exist for other people or that everybody
can just plow through them well and also
that community involvement is another
theme that runs through the book just
thinking about how science happens that
it's it's such a collaborative process
people building on other people's ideas
and bringing one piece of an idea to a
problem that someone else has
contributed another element and that we
it tends to be always about the eureka
moment and the you know the great white
man scientists but in fact it's it is a
network always
now i want to just skip forward a couple
of years there's there's a wonderful
anecdote in the book about another
life-changing moment that you have um
which is a conversation with the
legendary astronomer vera rubin who many
people believe should be you know nobel
laureate fury reuben
tell us about that exchange and and why
it mattered so much to you
so i met vera rubin i was introduced to
her and i really wish i could remember
who introduced me to her um
i was introduced to her at the 2009
women in astronomy conference which i
think was hosted at the university of
maryland
and basically the first thing that she
said to me is she said okay
so how do you think we should solve the
dark matter problem
and i was like so you know this is
almost 20 years later not quite 20 years
later but this is i'm pretty far i i'm
almost done with my phd
i'm at that point i was working on
cosmic acceleration also known as the
dark energy problem
and
i
didn't have an answer because i hadn't
thought about the dark matter problem
like at all partly because
nobody had ever asked me what my opinion
was
like i never i never thought it was
important for me to have an opinion
about it i didn't think that anybody
cared whether i had an opinion about it
and then suddenly i have
vera rubin who
found the first substantive evidence for
the existence of dark matter
asking me my opinion about it and so i
think that that planted the seed i will
actually say that the other important
piece of that experience with her
i had a couple of experiences with her
over the the next couple of days um so i
got to sit down and have lunch with her
and she spotted another like older lady
and was like nancy nancy come sit with
us
and i had no idea who this nancy person
was and she brings nancy over to the
table and sits her down and then looks
at all of us young
women and says you guys know who this is
right and we're all sitting there like
awkwardly and she goes this is nancy
grace roman this is the mother of the
hubble telescope right so it was also
important because she was giving us a
lesson in genealogy in astronomy and and
knowing your roots and knowing your
history and of course you know there's
the nancy grace roman telescope is going
to launch later this decade which i'm
pretty excited about right um but that
that was one of the lessons that i got
from her was not only ask the question
and
believe that you should have an answer
but also
know your history and knows know who the
women who walked
this space before you are
that's a high-powered lunch right there
there's a lot of
i would be very intimidated to sit at
that table i i'll tell you that
what a wonderful story well
that that takes us to
the science here um as you said you know
vera rubin was one of the first people
to detect evidence of what we call dark
matter
and this
this is actually a big part of what your
work is focused on
um
it is a fascinating idea that this idea
that
a significant portion perhaps the
overwhelming majority of the universe is
made up of this material dark matter
that we can't directly perceive
but as i'm sure you know it's a
counter-intuitive one it's hard for the
the non-scientists to really wrap their
heads around so
you're such a master explainer of these
things give us a brief
uh lesson here on
both what we think dark matter is or
what the range of debate is and and also
how do we even know that it's there
right so the way that um vera rubin and
kent ford first
detected
the the first substantive evidence for
the existence of dark matter was by
looking at how fast stars are orbiting
their galactic centers so stars are
orbiting galaxies
and if all of the mass in a galaxy so
all of the matter in the galaxy is just
the kind that we can see so the kind
that radiates light and interacts with
light
you would expect the stars to be moving
at a certain speed as you get further
and further out from the center
and what they saw was that the stars
were moving faster than expected
and
this is just like a very simple like
using frosh physics calculation
that this suggests that there's more
mass in the galaxy than what we were
calculating based on how much light was
being radiated so there's this mismatch
in the two different ways you can
measure the mass based on how much light
is being radiated and you can measure
the mass by looking at the
the how fast the stars are going and
there's a mismatch between these two
mass measurements so the two
possibilities that you have to consider
is that your theory of gravity is wrong
like you're just interpreting
the the data through the wrong theory or
it turns out that there's more mass than
we can see
and so that suggests that there is
what we what we call for historical
reasons dark matter there
and
by our current estimates using not just
those calculations and observations but
a whole slew of astrophysical
observations at this point we think that
dark matter is about 80
of the normally gravitating matter in
the universe so it's totally weird
it gravitates just like
visible matter does
so what we call visible matter or
luminous matter like the stuff like
everyday life right
but it doesn't seem to interact through
any of the other forces right so it
interacts through gravity but we have
not so far
detected interactions through the weak
nuclear force the strong nuclear force
or the electromagnetic interaction and
so
that presents us with this like very
strange scenario where it turns out that
most of
the universe is completely invisible to
us
the other issue i think is the word dark
itself now there's some fascinating
passages in the book about the
social and historical consequences of
the context of that word but i mean it
purely in the sense that i think people
intuitively think of dark things as
things that are
for instance in a dark room there's less
light and so things are dark or there
it's a darker shade whereas what we're
talking about here is matter that does
not seem to interact with light in any
form um
and so i i wonder whether there was a
better way even to to just describe it
that might have made it more immediately
you know
just how radical an idea it is might
have made it clearer to people
so i will tell you that actually the
thing that that this was the thing that
gave me the most anxiety about my ted
talk
that wasn't like what you were asking me
about
i'm here to make you as anxious as
possible that's that's very real
most of our proposed solutions to the
dark matter problem involve a new
particle
a particle that we've never seen before
and for for obvious reasons we haven't
seen it because it doesn't seem to
radiate light right but we haven't like
detected it in the lab and we're not
making things out of it or or any of the
like you know if you're a star trek fan
like i am
like none of that
um
but there is a possibility one
possibility is that it's made of
primordial black holes and so this comes
back to like where i had anxiety is that
in the scenario where it's a new
particle
i'm you really can't think of it as like
clear matter or transparent matter where
like light is just literally going
through it right so the example i gave
in my talk is if you have a clump of
dark matter in your hands you would feel
the weight of it but your hands would
look exactly the same like the the light
rays are going to go through it bounce
off your hand and
go into your
eye in the scenario where it's a
primordial black hole
then actually it is going to absorb the
light
and so then that i think primordial
black holes are the one dark matter
candidate that would actually justify
the name dark matter because it really
would be like taking light um away and
it would actually be absorbing it um so
that was kind of like the conundrum i
had was i was like someone's gonna be
like but if it's black holes it can't be
clear it can't be transparent i'll be
honest and say i don't think it's black
holes i think it's a particle so i'm
just gonna stick with i'm probably right
and if you are holding a primordial
black hole in your hand what what
happens
is holding you
and you're gone
okay we'll try to avoid that a safety
safety tip for kids listening at home
[Music]
you've actually referred to yourself as
an axion wrangler
tell us about axions and how they relate
to all this so i have to say that i'm
pretty sure that ryan mandelbaum the
science journalist that they're
responsible for first calling me an
axiom wrangler i'm but i've definitely
adopted that moniker
so the axion is a hypothetical particle
so it's again it's a particle that we
have never seen we haven't detected we
haven't worked with it so we don't know
if it's real
and the axion actually first arose as a
solution to a completely different
problem in particle physics
it happens to be that the axion first
came up as an idea in the late 1970s
which was around the time that vera
rubin and kent ford were first
you know publishing their data about
what we call rotation curves about stars
moving around their galactic centers and
essentially the reason that axions arose
as an issue is because in the standard
model of particle physics
this is the the picture that describes
all of particle physics there's a part
of it that we call quantum
chromodynamics also known as qcd
and this describes quarks and which are
these some atomic particles like
neutrons and protons are made out of
quarks
and
the general rule for doing the math of
the standard model this is like the
secret
the secret sauce to doing standard model
physics is
you keep adding
what we call terms to the lagrangians so
um you know pieces of the calculation
that you're allowed to add as long as it
doesn't violate any rules that we know
that the universe has to obey
um like the speed of light is finite
like we know that that's a rule it has
to obey
so you can add a term to this equation
that
there's no argument no theoretical
argument for why the term shouldn't be
there but when you do it makes a
prediction for something that we haven't
seen
so it causes the chart the neutron to
behave as as if it has a charge
distribution
you go in the lab and you look for that
neutron behavior and that that's not
there so there's now this disconnect
between like why
does the theory predict this and it
works beautifully for everything else
but this one thing but we're also not
seeing it in the lab
so the axion arises as a solution to
this problem to basically make that that
term and the equation go away
the people of roberto pechi and helen
quinn the the two theoretical physicists
who came up with this idea that was the
problem they were thinking about solving
and then not long after people were like
oh but there's a particle in here and it
can totally solve the dark matter
problem at the same time so frank
wilcheck called it the axion steve
weinberg called it the higlet as i said
if i talk right big missed opportunity i
grew up reading a a melon i'm a big
winnie the pooh fan
why is it not called the higlet like
what were you people doing
[Laughter]
so i'm i mean a world with higlets and
quarks is just a better world right
piglets and quirks like we're already
we're already on the literary side why
are we not continuing that trend right
and so frank wilcheck names
um named it after a laundry detergent
as one does i mean you know
in fairness this is like a classic
example of like somebody who was doing
like commercials or whatever
um or somebody on the marketing team was
like yeah do you know that greek
orthodox liturgy
axion why don't we use the axion esteem
for a laundry detergent name so that's
actually it is actually a literary name
but kind of like second hand right oh
that's so funny
i mean i think that one thing that's so
interesting about this field is that
discoveries
seem to come from two
fundamentally different directions on
the one hand they're all these stories
and we go going back to einstein and
before that of
mathematical equations formulas that
based on their internal logic seem to
predict the existence of phenomena that
we end up not actually detecting
for 80 years or 90 years in some cases
but we think from the math of it we
think there must be this this thing so
quantum gravity or something like that
right
on the other side of it you have so many
great stories like the fear ruben story
or like um
a cosmic background radiation story
where we have these sensors that are out
there in the world and they pick up data
that initially seems to us to be noise
like our antenna seems to be broken this
we can't be hearing this noise from all
around in all directions and and based
on that that input um from the external
world we then have to rejigger our
equations to make sense of it or invent
new theories and i feel like most other
fields either work in one domain or the
other but but this world seems to really
get insights from both those kinds of
approaches
i think like you know the overarching
lesson here is that um you know we are
not omniscient
so we can't actually predict where these
ideas are are going to come from and in
some sense the interesting scientific
questions that come up come up through
conflict
um and i don't mean violent conflict but
i mean conflict of like you know we
thought the universe was this way
but then you know we turned on our
little radio telescope and it's
detecting this line that no matter what
we do
doesn't go away
oh it turns out so in the case of the
cosmic microwave background radiation
which is what i'm talking about it turns
out that that's light that's been
traveling through the universe since
like about 400 000 years after
you know what we call big air quotes the
big bang
so we can't get rid of that signal
because it's literally all around us it
predates us by billions of years right
so now we have to come up with an
explanation for that in our scientific
models we now have to account for that
mathematically
and then you know you do get this flip
side where you have a mathematical model
that's working beautifully and then
something breaks and you're like wait
what
right and i think actually cosmic
acceleration is a good example of that
where you know we had this working model
of expanding space time
and now we have to explain why that
expansion rate is increasing why it's
accelerating and there's a way to
account for that mathematically
but
that mathematical explanation doesn't
necessarily help you out physically like
where did this
where did this thing come from
so i think that those those questions do
arise and i think it can be really
frustrating for people
who like to make um you know who like to
be in control
right
and and and who like to know where is
this going right because like the
practice the actual practice of doing
science is not knowing where it's going
and it is our job as scientists to live
at the boundary of what is known and
what is unknown and try and push that
boundary forward but it requires sitting
in your ignorance and being okay with it
and having some confidence that your
tools will allow you to push that
boundary outward
so it can be a very uncomfortable for
people who are like okay but you know i
want to be able to predict my bottom
line that's not what we do in science
right that's just not how it works it's
such a good point i mean i think it's it
it's something in the popular
description of science in the way that
we use it conversationally for folks who
are not
you know practicing scientists
the word scientific means
it's a it's an empirical fact it's a
known entity it's an uncontested truth
and in fact what science is in practice
is
a series of endless contestations of
truth and and pushing the boundary and
coming up with new things that challenge
the previous model and
it's not that we live in an entirely
relativistic world where there is no
truth but the truth is something you
slowly scratch away at over time and
if you assume that it's just set in
stone and everything is very clear and
science
has this authority that is absolute i
think you just misunderstand how it
works
and also the the excitement of it i
would think
i definitely think that there is kind of
this misunderstanding
and part of it is that you know the word
science just really has like multiple
definitions like sometimes when we're
saying science we mean the community of
people who engage in a set of practices
sometimes we're referring to those set
of practices
and it's not one practice it's actually
a set right so i'm there
physicists do science very differently
from archaeologists and from biologists
etc
and you know when it comes to the
question of like
what is the information that comes out
of those practices
if you're doing science well you're
characterizing your level of confidence
in that information and so it's never an
absolute statement if this is
definitively the truth
but you can say with high levels of
confidence
that this is probably how things are
working
and i think you know i get asked this
question about global warming a lot
which is like if there's no such thing
as a definitive statement then like
shouldn't people be skeptical about
whether global warming is happening
right but i think the point is is that
like sure there's like maybe some tiny
tiny tiny fraction of a possibility that
we're like wrong about this
but we're probably not wrong and whether
we're wrong or right if we make the
changes that are necessary for us to
make in order to
secure our future
for the next seven
10 20 generations
i'm it doesn't matter if global warming
is happening or not the world will be a
better place and the world will be
secured for them right so you're always
on some level there's always that
possibility that you're wrong but as
scientists we get really good at
characterizing what are the chances that
we're wrong and um you know once the
community we're we're consensus oriented
to come back to your comment earlier
we're extraordinarily social in science
often more so than our colleagues in the
humanities kind of ironically
so let's imagine we do get an answer to
the dark matter mystery
what are the stakes of of this kind of
question
so i'll start with the least popular
answer which is
one version of this answer is i don't
know right
so and to situate that in context
einstein
spent 10 years between special
relativity and general relativity he
comes up with general relativity
cool
he's brought gravity into conversation
with special relativity
now if you've used like google maps or
apple maps or something like that in
probably the last 24 hours is in in the
case of many of us
um it used calculations that relied on
general relativity because gps requires
general relativity another example is
the world wide web comes out of particle
physics experimentalists figuring out
better ways to communicate with each
other and so sometimes the answer is we
don't know what kind of impact it's
going to have but these
ideas and these discoveries are often
incredibly transformative in ways that
i'm can't be predicted a priori i think
the other piece of it
is
that it allows us to better understand
the greater cosmological story every
single human community has done
cosmological storytelling and so i think
that you know per
the the great black feminist um
philosopher of science sylvia winter
we are bios and mythoid we are a
storytelling species that we are
biocultural
um
it is in our dna i think probably
literally to tell cosmological stories
when we better understand dark matter
that allows us to better understand how
is space-time expanding what is the
future of that
and how does that interact with all of
all of maybe it does interact with
normal matter in some ways that we
weren't aware of and then it can get
really interesting in terms of like what
could we do with that technologically
um
but i think
knowing our universe is part of what we
do and i sometimes fear that in the rush
to think about things that are applied
that we forget
that this has value in the same way that
writing novels has value we are
storytellers and my work as a
cosmologist as a particle physicist is
storytelling at the end of the day and i
think that that is spiritually
nourishing for
us as a species
i want to come back to in some ways
where we started which is that i was
talking about how this this book and
your ted talk
manages to both talk wonderfully and
persuasively about physics and the
universe but also about
society today um
you have a line
i used to think physics was just physics
separate from people and i was wrong
tell us what you mean by that
when i was younger i believed that
physics and engaging in the practice of
physics
could just be a set of practices and a
set of ideas and that those two things
could be separated
from
who the people were
and
in the end science is a social activity
that involves people and you can't take
people out of it even if you know
someone i'm sure someone's sitting there
going but like what about a.i but at the
end of the day we make the ai and
there's like a plethora of evidence
right that like we also very quickly
teach the ai to be a total jerk right
like right that happens very very
quickly because it learns from us
so i think i had this very naive
perspective about it and i think part of
it honestly is that we're propagandized
about this and i use propaganda like
very intentionally here there's a
beautiful book by audra wolf who is an
independent historian
called freedom's laboratory
that's basically about the history of
science during the cold war and and
literally the idea that science was this
value-free practice
was
propaganda that was developed by the us
government and was proactively sent out
into classrooms as part of the cold war
effort to prove that like
western science and capitalist science
was superior to communism and communist
science and it's wild to think like my
teachers
were the children who were first exposed
to that and so they were passing on to
me this kind of like propaganda that
they were taught and so part of what i
wanted to do in the book and what i
wanted to help people do with themselves
was rethink what we have been told about
what science's social relations are
right
so one of the chapters that i found
particularly striking i think maybe
because it was more biological and thus
my brain could kind of connect to it a
little bit more directly um but is a
great example of you weaving together
the science and the kind of the social
history is this kind of extended
investigation you do of melanin the
molecule that's responsible for skin
color tell us a little bit about that
trajectory
yes i guess like ostensibly like my
thinking about melanin started with
going to the doctor and my doctor being
like your vitamin d levels are probably
low because for people who are black
they often are
um and that this is related to
the presence of melanin in your skin
and me being a scientist being like okay
well clearly i'm gonna like read about
that
and
you know even though i'm not supposed to
be like this i'm totally one of those
physicists who's like yeah well
everything comes back to physics at some
point
sure it's a molecule it's a biological
system whatever it's actually a
mechanical system
all the biologists have just turned off
the podcast in anger but that's okay
that's sorry small subset of our
audience you guys just have to deal with
it
so i
when i started thinking about melanin i
was pulling in all of these things about
my physics education my experience as a
physics researcher and realizing that
those things touched on melanin and that
i could actually think about physics in
relation to my own physicality
that physics was actually written on my
body in a way that i had i had not
thought about before
and that was a really powerful moment
for me and so i actually i wrote an
essay
about this for [ __ ] magazine
and then you know when i was putting the
book together it was like oh easy one
i can just like
adapt this and this is going to be the
easiest chapter in the book to write
and it was the hardest chapter in the
book to write and in fact the the
paperback is coming out and
that was the chapter i revised for the
paperback
interesting
i mean i think the
just this idea that there is a whole
immense and tragic history of
colonialism and slavery
that
on some level all orbits around
the spectral properties of this molecule
um
which gives you some sense of
how absurd that history was that you
would make whole decisions about who
should enslave whom and what power
dynamics should be between different
classes of people based on
the way this one molecule reflects or
doesn't reflect light
um
but bringing it all into
one single kind of explanatory history i
think is a it's just a really unique way
of looking at that that story
yeah honestly i think the challenge of
writing that essay was my initial desire
with the first version of it was i
wanted to tell
fellow black people
that melanin is amazing
because so many people grow up being
told that their melanin makes them ugly
and particularly for the most
highly melanated people in the the black
community the darkest skin people that
this is heightened because colorism is a
real phenomenon and so i really just
wanted to be like yo your skin is
awesome it's beautiful there's this
incredible molecule in it people are
actually
thinking with the molecule about how it
can inform our understanding of future
technologies
we're literally like talking like some
wakanda stuff here and that's like
that was part of what i wanted to
communicate and then when i came back to
revise it for the book
um it was 2019 and then it was 2020
and
increasingly i felt like i can't do this
without really acknowledging the pain
that comes with it and the history that
comes with it it was all a lot to do and
i think it probably deserves more than a
chapter
well i enjoyed it in chapter four but i
will happily read an entire book
treatment of it um
one of the
interesting arguments you've made
recently you made it on the ted stage is
this idea that we should actually rename
the newly uh
launched james webb space telescope for
harriet tubman so
walk us through her the way you kind of
connect her to
the history of space and the stars um
and why you think that would be an
appropriate act
so i believe and i think there's good
evidence for this that harriet tubman
used the the north star to guide people
to freedom
and um to guide herself to freedom and
i really can't think of a better use for
astronomy
than
liberating people from the extraordinary
and harrowing violence of chattel
slavery
that is the greatest use of astronomy
that there will ever be which is just
freedom work liberation work and so i
consider harriet tubman to be a great
american astronomer
she was not formally trained but frankly
back when she was doing that i'm nobody
was really formally trained in the
united states as an astronomer right
that wasn't phds weren't even really
being granted in the united states um
until around that point right so
i'm
you know
i think people have a tendency to be too
limited in thinking about who counts
and so i think that harriet tubman just
represents the best of humanity
and
when we're thinking about going to the
stars and going to look at the stars and
and the just wonderful space telescope
as i call it jwst
is going to see baby galaxies i'm like
super stoked about that and like hype
about it
and
i think that we should be sending the
best that humanity has to offer among
the stars and that harriet tubman fit
that and that james webb the current
namesake for the telescope i'm simply
did not i mentioned audra wolf's
freedoms laboratory earlier and part of
the story that she tells in the book was
the role that james webb played in the
development of psychological warfare as
a technique
um and so i object to
him being attached to the telescope for
that reason but i also object because he
played i'm
what i believe to be a key role in the
evolution of the lavender scare which
was basically the hunt for
lgbt people in federal government work
and we know that in at least one case
under his leadership at nasa that a gay
employee was arrested for being gay and
then was extra judicially interrogated
by the head of security at nasa and
subsequently fired and at that point in
time the culture at nasa was that a
decision like that would have come from
the administrator's office
i'm that's not the best of humanity
like we can just do better and and
harriet tubman harriet tubman represents
that so for me as a black queer person
who works on nasa projects and and
who was a nasa fellow that's what i want
um
the question we
ask all of our guests on this show which
i think you probably may have the most
profound answer to this given the scale
of of your work
um what in your field
is the great
unsolved problem that really drives you
what's the what's the thing kind of that
you would love to fast forward 10 years
and and find out what the scientific
consensus has become what's what's the
mystery that you're that you're most
intrigued by
i have two answers to this question i am
and i'm going to break your question a
little bit great fabulous
so
i'm obviously the question that seem
that drives me right now is dark matter
i really i want to know what dark matter
is i want to know where it is to what
extent does it maybe have some
interactions with standard model forces
like electromagnetism i i realized i
didn't say this earlier but pj peebles
then the nobel laureate cosmologist he
refers to it in his recent book from
princeton university press um a
subliminal matter so you know maybe it
does radiate light but not at the the
level that we can see it so i would like
to know does it radiate light how much
what frequencies that that kind of thing
so that's the question that drives me
but i don't want to fast forward because
if i fast forward then i actually miss
the experience of
like doing the math and working with my
students and
i think that you can be pretty miserable
as a scientist if you go into science
only wanting to get to the answers
and
not enjoying the process of getting
there because most of your life is the
process of getting there and sometimes
not getting there and so you have to
really enjoy the process of trying and
working things out
um i will say the question that i just
really want to know the answer to you
and i've decided that for the moment i'm
not working on and so i would be okay
with fast forwarding is i want to know
the answer to the cosmic acceleration
problem so i want to know what causes
cosmic acceleration if it is something
like the cosmological constant i really
need a better scientific explanation for
that than the anthropic principle which
says that it has the value that it does
because
if it didn't we wouldn't exist like it's
i find that to be a deeply
unsatisfactory answer and i just want
another one
[Laughter]
all right well we'll uh we'll have you
back in ten years and hopefully there
will be uh an answer to at least some of
those questions um
this has been a fascinating conversation
and i just keep coming back to a line
that really moved me in in the book um
which is maybe a good place to end which
is that you have this vision of of
wanting all children all children to
have access to the night sky um
it's it it does seem like your work is
doing a wonderful job of advancing and
fighting for that future so thank you
for
fighting that fight and being such a
great um and good-natured explainer of
all these complicated issues we really
appreciate having you on the show
thank you so much for having me
that's it for the show today the ted
interview is part of the ted audio
collective this episode was produced by
wilson sayer who's also our managing
producer the show is brought to you by
ted and transmitter media
sammy case is our story editor fact
checking by nicole bode vera de grunge
is our project manager and greta cohn is
our executive producer special thanks to
michelle quint anna phelan and ali
graham
i'm your host stephen johnson for more
info on my other projects you can follow
me on twitter at stevenbee johnson or
you can sign up for my substack
newsletter adjacent possible